[Music]
you needed a theme song so you call up
Paul Simon Simon may be the greatest
living American songwriter that's
alright yeah and you call him up and say
do my theme song please do a theme song
yeah and what happened there I wrote him
an email and I said I'm doing this new
series and I I won't like you to do the
theme song for it and and sing it and
perform it and and he wrote back and
said no he said let me ask my friend Joe
yeah yeah and I wrote again and it said
you know please yeah and he wrote back
and said all right what the hell what
the hell so I went to his studio and he
wanted to be like he wanted to be
accommodating so he would he played
something and then he'd go with how is
that like he wanted to collaborate he
wanted help you know like people
collaborate with him on music he wanted
me to I wanted to know my feelings about
stuff and that's like a serious thing
like it means he needs help you know so
he's like he plays somebody goes what do
you think and I'm like it's amazing I'm
no use to him because I'm like that was
beautiful he's like you know I mean how
can I do it differently I'm like just
keep being the great it's like if God
made a waterfall minutes like I don't
know what do you think I start actually
giving him fake things like you know I
don't know a little more energy in that
part it's and he's like oh good I'm like
I love that you're in a situation you're
telling Falls it yeah pick it up a
little bit I think it'll pick it up
below there Paulie yeah that's fantastic
and it worked out yeah so it's on this
on this I sent him all the scripts and
he wrote this beautiful song and it's on
the track it's an original sign he's
putting on in his new album so it's also
going to be on his out
you